[Music]
if you want to be successful learn from
the other people's mistakes don't learn
from the successful stories understand
the mistakes they made and don't make
those and understands the things that
work for them and apply that to your
life I get everything wrong it's just
that I can't recall it because once it's
wrong I'm moving on to the next thing
rise and shine it's an espresso time
what's that believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent at something and I want you to
find it embrace it and make a difference
using it so let's start your day off
right grab your cup of coffee and sip on
today's message learn from the mistakes
of others over to you Jack Ma my
thinking is that you guys remember if
you want to be successful learn from the
other people's mistakes don't learn from
the successful stories successful
stories they make don't listen to that
there are a lot of reasons behind it
just like god I remember the first time
Harvard Business School came to us say
Jack we want to write a case study for
you
yes years 2001 a 2000 they came they
spent one week and they write a report
and I really know I said this is not me
and this is this is you as a no this is
not us he said this is you so they make
IV sign and the case study go up and
instead to teaching love universities
the next of five years they invite to
need to go to the case study and they
always find a competitor of my company
and F after every case that case study
Ali Papa would die that company will
succeed all the students are green and
actually every five years all the
competitive dive is to survive so how
can you study this kind of a success of
a star
learn from the mistakes the other people
no matter how smart you are you will
encounter these mistakes you learn from
mistakes not because you will be able to
avoid mistakes you were able to when
these mistakes come they suffer comes
you know how to deal with it how to face
it I like the book I want to write if I
if I want if I can
it's a re Bubber 1001 mistake this is
the most rational things that in my life
in my life is not how much we achieved
is how much we go through the tough days
and mistakes and this is what you see if
you start to think now would be good if
there is a shortcut to your path to
success it'll come by modeling others by
modeling the things that work for them
by understanding things that didn't work
for them and applying it to your own
situation Bill Gates saved my first
company I've never met Bill Gates maybe
I will one day there's still time some
of the people in my wall here have
passed on but he saved my company
because when I was really struggling
with my business and I was trying to
figure out how do I grow this thing it's
not working I'm making 300 bucks a month
you know I did decently well at school I
had these huge job opportunities I'm I'm
I'm smarter than this like why is this
not working out it wasn't for lack of
effort I was putting in work every
single day to try to get this business
off the ground and yet nothing was
working for me and then by studying the
story of Bill Gates and understanding
how he built Microsoft how Microsoft
their big deal came with IBM when every
IBM shipped had Microsoft software on it
and that blew the company up but
Microsoft is already seven billion
dollars seven billion that's seven
billion seven million dollar company
when they made that deal which is small
compared to what it is now but it was
seven million more than what I had when
I was getting started how did he get
from zero to seven million
same thing through partnerships
partnerships partnerships and so I
leveraged that strategy and applied it
to my business and within a couple
months had my first deal of thirteen and
a half thousand dollars when I'm making
three hundred bucks a month thirteen and
half k's a ton of coin and more
importantly
strategy to use again and again and
again and again so that idea of modeling
the Masters modeling both the both the
failures and successes of people who've
come before me so that they may have
taken decades to figure that out I can
apply it quickly to my life and that's
my sincere hope with you guys when this
channel is to not have to watch
somebody's top ten rules and apply
everything to your life but just figure
out what works for you the ultimate goal
is not to be the next jack Mar the next
Steve Jobs the next Oprah Winfrey or
whoever it is it's to be the best you
and to do that you can pull one thing
from Jack Ma and one thing from Steve
Jobs and one thing from Oprah Winfrey to
help you be the better you and ignore
everything else if you just go down your
path trying to figure things out as you
go without ever having a compass and a
map it's gonna be much more difficult
you may stumble your way to some kind of
victory but if you had a map and you had
a compass and you knew the direction
you're going you had guidance along the
way it's just so much easier to get
there it doesn't mean that there still
aren't obstacles it doesn't mean that
it's still not painful it's still gonna
be the most difficult thing you ever do
in your life trying to build this
business up but the way through the way
to get there faster who had to get there
easier the way to get there with us as
little suffering as possible is to model
the people who have come before you
understand the mistakes they made and
don't make those and understands the
things that work for them and apply that
to your life to your business it won't
be exactly like the way Bill Gates
structured the deal with IBM was not
exactly what I needed to do to help my
business grow
but it's 95% of the way by taking on
somebody else's strategy it's 95 percent
of the way you just need to tweak it
tweak it for your industry to go for
your business tweak it for your
personality so that it works if there is
one hack to winning its modeling the
people who have come before you and I
hope you get the message if you're a fan
of this channel you probably do already
now it's just doing it more consistently
every single day filling your head with
knowledge from the people who have come
before you to help you become the best
version of you is the game now I've got
a quick bonus clip for you but before
that I want to know who have you modeled
you know who has been one of the
greatest sources of inspiration for you
someone that you've never met you've
watched a video you've read a book
listen to
Podcast who is that person what have you
learned from them I want to be inspired
I'm curious to hear from you leave it
down the comments below thank you guys
so much for watching I believe in you
I hope we continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot of espresso and
enjoy the bonus clip
[Music]
so many people come up to me and say
Gary it's so hard I look at their
Instagram and they're not posting any of
their content with hashtags which is a
by accident way to pick up exposure in a
world where they have no money when you
have no money when I took over my dad's
business it did 3 million dollars a year
10% gross profit $300,000 before
expenses my first year marketing budget
was $14,000 when you have no money and I
built that business from a three to a
sixty million dollar business in five
years I had to make every penny perfect
so I was right about email marketing in
96 and I was right and because of that I
had 91% open rates when Google AdWords
came out the day it came out I paid five
cents a click for words before anybody
bid me up and I was super right and that
worked if it is that luck versus
preparation and do you ever get anything
wrong what do you do I can make them as
I think I give everything wrong it's
just that I can't recall it because once
it's wrong I'm moving on to the next
thing
like dwell dwelling on what you bond is
the quickest way for the next thing not
to work right yeah
so like so I think I do everything I
mean you know this this is a fun thing
to say some people in the back know this
I was a breakout YouTube star in the
first year 2006 I decided that the right
strategy was to leave YouTube completely
and go to viddler because viddler
offered me equity in their company and
I've left an enormous amount of
attention I deviated from my intention
thesis to do short-term economics and
equity in a company and I lost I lost
Wendy Brock finally came in my life two
years ago we started to try to build up
my youtube for the first time I was
sitting on 40,000 user followers in a
world where I could have had millions if
I just stayed the course so I make
mistakes all the time
I'm reorganize its based on a mistake I
made the prior year I just don't give a
my mistakes everybody else cares about
your mistakes if you're worried about
your own mistakes you've already lost
every time I made a mistake
they became painful mistakes but with
time I realized that reflecting on those
mistakes would give me gems what I would
do is I'd say why did I make that
mistake and I would learn from that
mistake and I'd write down a rule so
what was helpful for me is I put that
rule principles these
Sybil's I wrote these principles now
those principles that I wrote down I
then put into algorithms in other words
equations and what I learned by being
able to do that is find if I took my
decision criteria those principles and
then I tested them back through time I
gained a perspective that was fantastic
I could test them in the back a hundred
years I could test them in different
countries and I would learn how those
rules work and I'd put by putting all
those rules together and then how having
these algorithms the computer could
replicate my thinking but it could
actually think better than I could
because what it would do is it would
take it can process more information it
can process it faster and it could
process it less emotionally so it was
like having a GPS that was next to me
while I was also making my decisions
like you're driving in a car and you
have both operating and to have that
next to me was you know invaluable it
would learn I would learn and together
we built that volume you have the most
important work ever if you had to think
of one word that's most important to you
or that sums you Apple that would be
like a little beacon hey believe nation
if you want to know what the most
important one word is for Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am
and Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details